mahomes clean pocket throwing long he
wants tyree kell makes it catch 20 15 10
5 touchdown
kansas city a
67-yard bomb and tyreke hill becomes the
all-time leading receiver in single
season in chief's history
you know last year about this time i was
beginning to hear some rumblings that
the chiefs were considering trading
cornerback marcus peters i was shouted
down by pretty much everyone who covers
the chiefs as an idiot who knows nothing
about which he speaks that's not
necessarily incorrect but i got lucky on
this one because they did trade marcus
peters and it stunned everyone well they
almost took it next level this year
according to jay glaser of the athletic
in a mailbag column where he created a
stir a few weeks back when he called his
shop for the offseason the bold
prediction otto beckham jr getting
traded glazer at it again saying that he
had heard rumblings of a tyree kill
trade before word came out last week
he's being investigated for child abuse
my goodness peter the kansas city chiefs
without tyree kill who i believe is the
most dangerous non-quarterback in the
entire nfl it makes me wonder why and my
first thought is he just wants way more
money than the chiefs could ever pay
both to him and to patrick mahomes over
the long haul
well that would be part of it but uh
i've found this over time mike any
player who andy reed really wants to
keep
if he really wants to keep somebody he's
going to find a way
and uh when i saw that
in jay glazer's mailbag the other day
yesterday i guess
uh i immediately said because i'm like
you if jay has something like that it's
something that he's definitely hearing
and it's something that probably has
some legs to it
um and and i would i would just think
two things
i would just think that andy reid
hears and sees and feels a lot of things
around his team
that the vast majority of people on the
outside and everybody on the outside
would not hear
and you know you go back oh my god he's
trading donovan mcnabb in the division
oh how could he do that that's crazy
turned out to be a great idea oh he's
letting this guy go i mean just look at
all the times that andy reid has made
decisions personnel wise going back to
marcus peters last year obviously
but look at all of these decisions he's
made and there always seems in
retrospect to be a reason for him so
that's the first thing and then i think
the second thing is
andy reid has got the ultimate trump
card
he says listen
if i've got
patrick mahomes on a rookie deal for two
years more at least and i can't build
the shell of a super bowl team
even if i have to do it without the most
dangerous offensive weapon in football
there's something wrong with me
so if he is dubious
about the prospect
of the long-term playing prospect or the
fact that he just thinks he's going to
cost way too much
then i could see this happening but
again
i just know this there's more to this
story than meets the eye we don't know
it right now
so i think everybody should just stay
tuned and see what happens and i'm and
and i don't know everybody says oh king
knows some i don't know anything
but again
there's some interesting smoke here and
usually andy reid is a pretty good
private investigator
and i think now what we have to do is
basically wait and see what happens with
this investigation because if tyreek
hill is cleared i still don't see the
chiefs making the move to sign him to a
long-term contract now i think
everything gets tabled until next year
that's when he would be on the cusp of
the franchise tag peter and maybe just
like d ford this year you tag him and
you trade him and that may be the end
result for tyree killing kansas city
could be and and you know it's it's very
interesting mike because
you know i talked to somebody in kansas
city close to the chiefs before the uh
you know before the free agency period
who said look andy wants to trade d ford
but as of right now
he's got no legitimate takers
in part because there's too many teams
out there right now who think that
paying a one-year
kind of uh
you know star because you know basically
d ford had one really good year for the
chiefs you know they're worried about
paying him franchise doe von miller type
doe
uh for having one year and not being
positive about the guy so even if he has
to take a lesser draft pick a second or
third he'll do it it turns out they did
get some traffic on that and the 49ers
mike in the underrated contract of free
agency basically can walk away from d
ford after a year maybe two and not be
heard
at all really
you know one more thing about tyreek
hill we saw what the patriots did in the
afc championship game to take him away
and it it it wasn't like they devoted
five guys to him all they did was put
someone over the top and the truly great
receivers and i don't want to take
anything away from tyreek hill but the
truly great receivers still get open
when they have that safety that rolls
over the top and tyree kill had one
catch in the afc championship game so
maybe andy reid looked at that and
thought you know the guy's really fast
the guy's really good but he's not randy
moss he's not a guy that's going to be
able to beat double team so maybe he's
not a guy worth 20 million a year
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports